[Music]
so where are you on love island
we stopped watching we definitely didn't
take a cut here yeah yeah definitely not
yeah we definitely didn't talk for like
five minutes about something else
i haven't seen it in like a week and a
half yeah uk what's the uh the last
thing i saw was after the movie night
yeah it was like i watched like two or
three episodes after that you are a liar
yeah not does anything happen does
anyone break up
the thing that i'm most surprised about
is that paige
and [ __ ] adam are just like
it's like jax never happened bro i don't
understand how any like nobody's talking
about this
bro
like picking them up from the airport
like
just crawling yeah that's the only one
but then everyone's like yeah paige
should be off and it's like yeah but you
i don't understand what i'm not and i'm
not blaming her i'm just saying like i
don't understand what happened he left
and then it's like he never existed yeah
they must have told her like just act
like he
just he's dead to you now crack on with
this new guy because everyone wants to
see you with him jax was a psycho anyway
he was a [ __ ] psycho but i don't
think we saw the like how psycho yeah
you think there's less or more more yeah
i think there's more yes i think there's
definitely more i think there's like we
didn't see some [ __ ]
under not under great pretenses you know
oh you think he's like oh i'm just gonna
go
i mean they made it seem like he was
like oh i'm not i'm not being myself
like i'm not this is i think he's jack
dude yes i feel like he probably gotten
like a physical altercation with someone
or broke the rules yeah so he got like
basically disqualified yeah and they
were like you have to leave yeah but
we're gonna save face for you and make
it seem like it was your decision and
maybe it was sort of like the writing
was on the wall for page
in some moment leading up to it yeah i
think so like maybe like i could see him
spazzing and she in her mind is checks
out right there and says ah nah yeah
this dude yeah because even when she try
to talk him off a ledge and say what
does this accomplish what are you trying
to do and he's like i don't know
if you [ __ ] [ __ ] come here yeah
yeah she's like all right yeah we're
done here i just thought it was funny
how like just no explanation and then
all of a sudden she's in a relationship
with this new guy and everyone's like oh
we love them together like it just
didn't even happen
when you told me that adam is too
charismatic and it creeps you out yeah
got that [ __ ] immediately oh yeah dude
you know what's creepy so well not
creepy but so in the first season he was
21 and he was kind of timid
you know and he he seemed like this who
is that marvel villain in that
giant spaceship it's like gamora's dad
with the big staff what is that [ __ ]
asshole's name oh tony pizza tony pizza
that's what adam was like he's like this
[ __ ] darth vader of the
i don't know who cares you know adam
comes in and in the first season he's
like i've been with over a hundred girls
and everyone's like oh my god this guy's
crazy and then he uh comes back this
season and he's more mature yeah he's
grown up a little bit yeah and that
smile he does like he's beaming at
people he knows what his game is well
that's what that's what his game is it's
saying he's older and more mature and
done with this old lifestyle that
that is his [ __ ] line he uses that
[ __ ] and paige is like oh my god i found
a man yeah it's like oh my god the way
the way he said that i've been here once
before yeah that was a marvel villain
yeah yeah i'm surprised like they didn't
introduce him like that like all the
girls walk out into the villa and he's
just on the lawn it's just
like oh yeah he just lands on it
you've been waiting for me
i do believe there's a bit of trouble in
the future
oh my god what else happened we were
wrong about ekkinsu people love her
and davide yeah people love them i kind
of like them that's what i'm saying
every [ __ ] opinion i have in the
beginning of the show turns out to be
wrong yeah every single one even though
i i still don't like her the internet
really likes her i'm not really a fan
but i also was like they don't really
seem that good together i was like dave
davide's faking this clearly nah but
weirdly they're so opposite that it
works no i i think they actually remind
i think they're the most relatable
because i feel that they have that long
time couple behavior sometimes
yeah like when they get in their little
petty arguments yeah i'm like that that
[ __ ] that elena and i were laughing like
dude this is us like arguing about like
leaving the sink on right here yeah so
we'll know you always leave it on yeah
yeah but i don't leave it on yeah i
don't leave it on because it's like just
they have that [ __ ] yeah 102
podcast speed argument
and i think that's why people love it
yeah and i think there's something
really juvenile about the both of them
where she like does something and he's
like oh it's i think it's also that he's
weirdly very sensitive about her yeah
out of everyone he i feel was uh the
most like i don't want you to hurt my
feelings yeah which is i think super
relatable yeah and he like always stayed
true yeah he never really talked to
anyone else i mean besides sucking
danica's face oh yeah right coco's face
oh yeah right but he was always like
really honest yeah you know he was
always like yeah like i kissed two girls
because you are upsetting me
[Laughter]
he should have him on the show i would
love to have him on crimson chin yeah
him and eken sue yeah i would love that
she can be like what what is it that you
don't like about me yeah oh my god and
make you say it to her face
then i would just be a coward i've
always liked you
you're my favorite tony pizza
who else is together dummy india so who
do we think is going to win david and i
can sue probably probably them
them or gemma and luca i guess nah that
ain't that yeah people don't like him
i don't like him dude the movie night
[ __ ] was so funny when they're like that
it's gotta be i i so like i i said that
uh casso moore is the most electric hour
of television but it's not the movie
night is truly the most electric hour of
television out of all the shows yeah
it's insane the whole time i'm glued to
the [ __ ] screen like oh my god i
can't believe it's and it's amazing that
it's amazing they know what's gonna
happen
and still they talk [ __ ] and still
yeah the guy cheating with every girl
is
watching lucas dress eat is so funny
yeah oh yeah they're all these big ass
chompers
[Music]
yeah it looks like me with a pop-tart
yeah
yeah nice give me a nice comparison man
listen to me the pots are i'm so tired
[Music]
cuz i'm in the ponds
i'm so tired
yeah [ __ ] hiking
yeah [ __ ] me up dude we should just
throw you down a hill you'll be [ __ ]
ready if you can endure that pain you'll
be fine that's the that's the it's the
downhills that's what the [ __ ]
ride scene
[Laughter]
play this
didn't we watch this like three months
ago
[Applause]
holy [ __ ]
bro you know oh you know you should do
for that hike what just use the super 73
hill climbing bike for the first [ __ ]
half it'll be electric so no gasoline
i would love to
honestly
you